good afternoon I'm Lieutenant David
Valenta of using Victor
a-l-e-n-t-a with the ovmpd homicide sex
crimes Bureau here to brief you on a
current preliminary ongoing
investigation into a homicide
Metro dispatch received a call at about
12 30 uh this afternoon indicating that
a male had been shot Patrol officers
responded at which time they did find a
male who was being described as a 34
year old male who was uh injured and
then pronounced deceased on scene from a
gunshot wound
that is currently in the 5200 block of
Tipper Ave in the far Southeast side of
town
uh very preliminary right now we're
still canvassing looking for Witnesses
video talking to people very preliminary
details uh it sounds like there was an
altercation possibly over a limited
parking in the street cars blocking each
other which then escalated uh between
some residents in the area at which time
uh our believed suspect produced a
handgun and fired a couple rounds at
which time our victim was struck and
down on the scene our suspect has left
the scene we're still making attempts to
thoroughly identify him before any
apprehension we encourage the public as
always anyone with any information
regarding this event please reach out to
Metro Police you can stay Anonymous
through Crime Stoppers you can email
Metro homicide a homicide at lvmpd.com
with any information
also related to this uh additional news
that was created is because this
neighbor Hood does butt up immediately
to the south end of Courtney Junior High
School
as typical police procedures when we
have a shooting unknown suspect at that
it's uh we put the Schools on lockdown
as we did in this case sounds like there
was some miscommunication some kids have
been immediately right outside had heard
the gunshots so between that confusion
of calling to lock down to school kids
going inside saying they heard gunshots
somehow that got communicated through
cell phones text messages into a
possible active shooter police responded
to that and proved that that was a false
miscommunication there was no threat at
any time at the school school PD was
immediately on scene Metro immediately
responded to assist and everybody was
safely accounted for and evacuated out
of that school so any concerns I can
alleviate from the school just a
miscommunication being immediately next
to a crime scene where gunshots were
heard with that any questions does
anyone
struck by gunfire or injured in any way
other than at this time we have
information on a single victim any
uh just a 34 year old male that we
believe lives in the area
I don't have that information for you
sir
we believe it is somebody in the
neighborhood as far as immediate
neighbor or how many doors down uh I
can't say and that has not been 100
confirmed yet
nothing has been 100 confirmed yet still
ongoing very preliminary
living inside the home where they
interview I have no information on kids
very preliminary still haven't even done
search warrants still have to go
everything I cannot account for any
handguns any of that which we hope to
find uh after you know search warrants
thank you very much thank you